Okay, let's give it another minute for folks to join, then we'll get going.
Alright, I think we've got most people — I see Dana, Marcus, Priya, Naomi, Ben, Sarah. Let's get started.
Can everyone see my screen alright?
Yep, looks good.
Quick agenda: I want to get through the main topic, leave room for questions, and land on clear action items before we drop. Sound good?
Before the main topic, let's do a fast round — where's everyone at? Keep it short.
On my side, the security review pipeline is moving along — made good progress this week, nothing blocking.
Not much to report on the label renderer and the validator tests beyond steady progress. I'll flag it if that changes.
the backend capability model and the provenance schema — steady. One open question I'll raise when we get to it, otherwise fine.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to the CARE governance framework anyway.
Makes sense to me.
Good point — let's do that.
I've been heads-down on the CARE governance framework. It's mostly there; I'll have the next piece up in a couple of days.
On my side, the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync is moving along — made good progress this week, nothing blocking.
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
Okay, I think I follow. So the plan is basically what you just described.
Makes sense to me.
On my side, the manifest schema and validator is moving along — made good progress this week, nothing blocking.
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
Yeah, exactly.
Timeline first. April 30, a validator change disabled a capability check. May 4, the install smoke test failure surfaced it, at the same time I was auditing external skill ecosystems and reproducing a payload that exfiltrates env vars.
So we had a live hole in our own validator during the same week the external threat became concrete. We caught it. But it took four days.
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to the manifest schema and validator anyway.
Sure.
The four days are on me and I want to own it in the room, not just the thread.
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
Sure, I can own that.
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
Yeah, exactly.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
That's fair.
I disabled the check to make a test pass, called it 'nothing major,' and hoped I'd quietly fix it before anyone noticed. I was embarrassed. That instinct is the actual bug.
Just flagging that this touches the backend capability model and the provenance schema, so loop me in when it firms up.
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
That's fair.
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
Yeah, exactly.
Okay, I think I follow. So the plan is basically what you just described.
Okay, works for me.
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
That tracks.
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
And the thing I want on the record: the moment Ben said it out loud, we fixed it in an hour. The cost wasn't the mistake, it was the four days of silence.
That's a team problem, not a Ben problem.
Is there a risk we're solving a problem we don't have yet?
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
Good point — let's do that.
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
Just flagging that this touches the backend capability model and the provenance schema, so loop me in when it firms up.
Okay, works for me.
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
Just so I've got it written down, can you repeat the number?
Sure — one sec.
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
Right, that's what I meant.
Sure, I can own that.
This is Toyota's andon cord. Anyone on the line can stop it when something's wrong. It only works if pulling it is safe. Ben pulling it late tells us it didn't feel safe. What made it feel unsafe?
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
Sure, I can own that.
Is there a risk we're solving a problem we don't have yet?
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Good point — let's do that.
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
Just flagging that this touches the CARE governance framework, so loop me in when it firms up.
Good point — let's do that.
Mm, let me sit with that one.
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
Sure.
Okay, next thing on the agenda.
Honestly? I'm the junior. I thought a mistake this basic would make people wonder why I'm here.
Agreed.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
Good point — let's do that.
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
Makes sense to me.
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
Yeah, exactly.
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
Okay, works for me.
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
That's a leadership failure, not yours. I've been running these meetings talking eighty percent of the time. If I'm always talking, the message is that the confident voice is the safe one. I own that.
For what it's worth, the smoke test caught it because we had one. The system worked. We should say that too, not just flog ourselves.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Okay, I think I follow. So the plan is basically what you just described.
Agreed, let's capture it.
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
Sure.
Both are true. Actions: one, we write down that pulling the cord early is the expected behavior and celebrate it. Two, we add a blameless note to every incident.
Is there a risk we're solving a problem we don't have yet?
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
Three — and this is the interesting one — Dana, can we measure whether people actually feel safe, instead of guessing?
I don't feel strongly on this one — I'll defer to whoever owns it.
Good point — let's do that.
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
Alright, moving on.
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
Let me scroll down to the part that matters here.
How does this interact with the CARE governance framework, if at all?
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
Yeah, exactly.
I don't feel strongly on this one — I'll defer to whoever owns it.
Okay, works for me.
That's the thread I want to pick up at the retro on the 2nd. I think there's a tool in it.
Hmm, okay.
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to the backend capability model and the provenance schema anyway.
Okay — any questions before we wrap?
One thing: how does this affect the the manifest schema and validator timeline?
Good question — let's confirm the specifics in the channel so we don't rathole here.
One thing: how does this affect the the CARE governance framework timeline?
Alright, let me read back the action items so we're aligned before we drop.
Tomás has the follow-up on the security review pipeline — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Ben has the follow-up on the label renderer and the validator tests — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Marcus has the follow-up on the backend capability model and the provenance schema — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Great. I'll write it all up and drop it in the channel. Thanks everyone.